paul réflexe adresse précision le
ball-trap mêle plusieurs compétences
cette activité de tir sportif est
pratiqué par 150 à 200 personnes à
l'année chaque week-end en forêt de
rambouillet et deux disciplines sont
proposées au sein du ball-trap
rambolitains ont fait que des
disciplines qui ne sont pas olympique
donc ici ces parcours de chasse et
compact sporting
alors ces deux disciplines différentes
et y en a ici vous êtes sur une surface
d'à peu près 100 m² avec plusieurs
postes avec un menu des fils défilant et
à la fin vous avez tiré 25 plateaux et
vous avez le compact sporting ou là vous
avez être les gens sont les uns à côté
des autres car chacun cinq plateaux sur
chaque poste et après échange de postes
sur sa position le tireur choisi son
plateau ils sont différents les
trajectoires peuvent être tendues ou
encore en parabole le plateau peut être
également roule en imitant le
déplacement au sol d'un lapin une fois
en place il n'y a plus qu'à actionner
cette télécommande
donc ça c'est une télécommande qui
permet d'envoyer les plateaux et de
suivre les menus que vous avez les
lettres ici sur le menu ya l'alcool et à
la lettre à quand la personne est prête
et appelle le plateau à on appuie sur le
bouton à
hélas hélas le plateau 120 hommes
longtemps prisé par les seuls chasseurs
le ball-trap s'ouvre peu à peu de
nouveaux pratiquants se lance comme
anaïs inscrits au club depuis l'été 2010
est elle souhaite s'entraîner avant de
se tourner vers quelques compétitions à
ce qui me plaît c'est que ça demande
beaucoup de concentration que ça défoule
on sort de là on a la tête vidée et et
on se sent bien c'est
c'est un sport qui est assez complet
fait de trois ans où on sent qu'il ya de
plus en plus de monde qui vient alors
nous dans un cadre peut-être cadre qui
fait que les gens viennent chez nous
investi énormément tous les ans on
investir dans la cabane et c'est donc
c'est du bouche à oreille et les gens
aiment bien venir ici
vous pratiquez le ball-trap est tout de
même onéreux compte et 1500 euros pour
vous équiper d'un fusil performant